la crise sanitaire a retardé plusieurs
fois l'application de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais mercredi les
dernières mesures sont entrées en
vigueur un volet qui a modifié les
règles de calcul des droits touchés et
vivement critiquée par de nombreux
politiques et syndicats ces derniers ont
ainsi appelé nouvelle fois à une
manifestation d'ampleur aujourd'hui
contre le chômage et de la précarité
d'un cortège on trouve notre reporter
david kelly faire
bonjour david alors quelles sont les
revendications
[Musique]
19e mobilisation annuelle contre la
précarité le chômage dans les rues de
paris à ce samedi une année 2021
particulière pour ces manifestants en
ligne de mire évidemment l'assurance de
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
depuis le 1er octobre elle est entrée en
vigueur en plusieurs étapes avec
notamment le mode de calcul de minimum
pour pouvoir avoir une indemnisation
passant de 4 à 6 mois sur les derniers
25 24 mois une réforme tout simplement
scandaleuse ans pour la plupart des
manifestants présents ici un cortège
d'environ une centaine de personnes
encadrées par un important dispositif de
sécurité plutôt des mesures et 1 par
rapport au nombre de manifestants le
cortège se poursuit il dénonce
évidemment à cette réforme assurance
chômage mais ils dénoncent également la
précarité qui s'est largement amplifié a
notamment à cause de la crise sanitaire
écouter
aujourd'hui le gouvernement il
accompagne toutes les cases d'emplois il
a accompagné et ford ford à blanquefort
y avait un repreneur possible le ford
n'a pas voulu qu'un entrepreneur l'état
il s'est couché là aujourd'hui l'état il
est actionnaire de renault renault
abandonne les salariés de la sam à
viviez dans l'aveyron le gouvernement
qui se couche il ment aux salariés mais
il va se coucher ouais donc c'est
inacceptable donc le gouvernement l'état
il doit arrêter d'être bras armé du
capital les précaires ont été les les
doubles ou triples victimes de l'ère de
la crise sanitaire parce que non
seulement ils subissaient déjà la
précarité
ce sont ceux qui se retrouvent et
violemment au chômage parce que la
plupart des chômeurs veille mais là il
se retrouver sans travail du tout il ya
eu quelques mesurettes pour les
accompagner mais derrière on leur tape
dessus et l'activité partielle par
exemple n'a pas couvert les cdd elle à
protéger les emplois en cdi elle n'a
pratiquement pas couvert les emplois en
cdd qui se sont retrouvés
en fin de contrat au chômage pas
indemnisés est maintenant en fin de
droit et en durcissant les droits c'est
absolument scandaleux ce sont les
précaires qui payent la crise et on le
voit très clairement avec l'augmentation
de la pauvreté l'augmentation des files
d'attentes devant les soupes populaires
c'est ça c'est des choix politiques de
macro et de son gouvernement qu'ils sont
inacceptables une élue politique
également et présentant dans le cortège
la seule à son grand désarroi à la
maire-adjointe de
d'ivry-sur-seine déplore justement le
nombre le manque de présence un des élus
de gauche pointe et son taux de chômage
une question finalement caractérise le
parti elle est partie et de gauche et 10
les bataillons gros comme élu
aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est un
problème que la gauche que les élus de
gauche ne pense pas que leur place est
là avec les plus précaires les plus
pauvres les chômeurs pour moi c'est un
problème moi je viens tous les ans je
crois que c'est très important de
soutenir les luttes
des chômeurs et des travailleurs
précaires
hormis la suppression de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et de la précarité
les habitants présents ici un réclame un
emploi ça qu'ils soient bien rénumérés
et tout soit socialement utiles des
milliers d'élements la précarité
grandissante
le cortège se poursuit aucun débordement
à signaler et devrait terminer sa course
aux invalides a dit si une petite heure
merci beaucoup à david pour toutes ces
précisions